poet who moved strangers with his words
in just a matter of minutes shauna just
said please let vlad go
stop talking let me give giocero his due
geo sarah crafts poems on the spot on
any topic that people choose from love
and inspiration to addiction and
heartbreak he pounds out the words on an
old-fashioned typewriter and then shares
his creation and wellborkish shows us
how the poems are creating deep
emotional connections
when you meet gio cerro it's clear his
art space is anything but typical
keystrokes instead of brush strokes
small pieces of paper the blank canvases
he feeds through his vintage typewriter
he calls himself an on-demand poet
pecking at the keys stopping only when
deep in thought writing for strangers on
any topic they choose
tell me a little bit about humanity what
do you love about humanity and in just a
matter of minutes he creates a
connection together hands class together
we move toward a beautiful future i feel
connected to people
when i write a poem for them i'm digging
down deep so i can give you something
back you know i want to i want to move
you cerro started connecting with others
through the power of his words at a very
young age so i wrote one for my
grandfather for his birthday remember he
cried in that moment i think it
imprinted on me
that you could move people with words
but his passion for writing remained
only a hobby while his career took him
elsewhere landing his dream job working
for tesla i realized
as the couple months went on like i
didn't really like
what i was doing anymore there was no
passion i began to realize that writing
needed to be the thing that i i did
that leap of faith led to the creation
of geo's typos with paper and typewriter
in hand he writes just about anywhere
working as a poet for hire at events can
you write a love letter to my cat
sure
connecting with strangers and allowing
them to pay what they want for one of
his typed poems
why the typewriter there's no delete
button
and so it lends itself to geos typos
correct you embrace those imperfections
that uh we usually
delete now on a computer you get to see
my train of thought i think that's the
cool art part of it is that you watch me
create this poem but then you also watch
me like
mess up a little bit or not mess up or
write something i didn't like and go
back and then restart his poems cover a
range of topics he wrote one for two
best friends at this chamber of commerce
event when best friends are here we
always are in high spirits and the
social worker looking for the good in
humanity we turn hate into love and
someone simply in need of comforting
words i hope you find everything you
want
i promise to wish it on a well
marcia briggs turned to cerro on a
particularly dark day
it was just today that i realized i had
to put my cat down when i saw g.o
there it was almost like yes you can you
can
relay my feelings and my emotions i
really cherish the poem you know when
they cry i cry it's really hard because
i'm trying to think like how does this
person feel like what are they going
through where does that writing come
from
so i have a joke that i say that like
we're all walking around with our
emotional trash bag and when someone
comes and brings me something like that
i like i go in my trash bag and i start
searching for all the experiences that i
had that maybe i can relate to one of
your poems says i'm not writing poems as
much as i am writing permission slips
for people to feel their feelings
again what does that mean a lot of times
we i think we hold back our feelings so
what i do is i try to
bring those emotions right to the
forefront i want to give people
those feelings whatever it is that they
they want for me i want to i want to
give it back i like to think that i am
tangling much wiser emotions pouring out
just like when he puts words to paper
whatever you want to do for cbs
morning's manuel bajorquez saint
petersburg florida
you know guys i hadn't heard that phrase
emotional trash bags but i think that
that's so true i also find sometimes
it's easier to confide in strangers
than it is to people close to you when
you're going through something sometimes
how interesting is it though that when
you empty out that emotional trash bag
for him he writes you a poem about the
things you're going through and i love
the rawness of it using a typewriter
because when you use that
there's imperfections on the paper which
it parallels who we are there's
imperfections in all of us so you get
this this poem with scratches and marks
all over it yep but it's perfectly
imperfect just like we all are and you
get to keep it and you get to keep
things you get to keep nicely done
nicely